er ist dahin
hätten einfach schreibst und fuß und ist
einfach zu einfach
[Musik]
sie sind dann auf mich so gesprungen und
sagen sie uns mal wo die leiche ist und
ich war ja ziemlich überrascht ich
meinte ich wusste gar nicht wovon die
rede ist
der tag von andrea roth reges beginnt um
6 uhr mit kaffee und zigarette ein
tägliches ritual für die 35 jährige
mutter aus rafz im kanton zürich seit
2016 ist sie alleinerziehend spazieren
morgen
ich habe mich schon daran gewöhnen das
war ja vorher nicht anders und jetzt ist
es auch nicht anders irgendwie mein
alltag
was nimmst du möchtest ein glas saft
nein die drei mädchen sind sechs acht
und zwölf jahre alt und haben keinen
vater mehr mit 20 heiratete die slovakin
andrea mani so war ihre erste große
liebe
luis rodrigues was in der schweiz
romantisch begann endet in einer
katastrophe
luis rodrigues bringt 2016 in rafz einen
rentner um das opfer ist kino bornhauser
in diesem polizeiakten sind die letzten
minuten seines lebens dokumentiert für
seine frau petra eine große last
sie muss damit leben dass ihr mann von
dem sie getrennt lebte auf einem
parkplatz in rafz niedergeschlagen und
seine leiche bis heute nicht gefunden
wurde
dieses gefühl muss mehrfach mit dem
hauptmieter und dieser geschafft
die tat geschieht an einem freitag im
april 2016 kino bornhauser beobachtet
von einer bank auf eine ihm fremde
familie auf dem spielplatz es ist die
familie von luis rodrigues als dieser
zum spaß seine tochter in die luft wirft
ruft im zehner bornhauser zu ob er eine
gute lebensversicherung habe roth regel
fühlt sich provoziert geht zum rentner
sie streiten sich kurz darauf setzt sich
kino bornhauser in sein auto und wir
wegfahren er stoppt vor luis rodrigues
der gerade den parkplatz überquert
wieder kommt es zum streit
andrea rodriguez spielt zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch mit den kindern auf dem
spielplatz der streit auf dem parkplatz
eskaliert luis rodrigues schlägt kino
bornhauser brutal zusammen
dann hilft er den bewusstlosen rentner
ins auto mehrere zeugen sehen die tat
doch niemand alarmiert die polizei
petra bornhauser hat bilder des angriffs
auf ihren mann war eine anwohnerin die
tat mit ihrem handy filmte
dort sind sie da das hat er zeigt wenn
ihr quasi eine bewegende gott soll
klinisch während deutschland ziemlich
wahrscheinlich bewusstlos gesehen an
einem waldrand lädt luis rodrigues den
bewusstlosen rentner aus dem auto und
überfährt ihn mehrmals
er will sicher sein dass er tot ist die
leiche deponierter danach an einem
unbekannten ort im wald und fährt weg
zwei tage später findet die polizei ein
ausgebranntes auto im grenzgebiet zu
deutschland
es gehört schien oberen hause von dem
jede spur fehlt einfach alles musste
medienerfahren polizei sehr
zurückhaltend erst fünf tage sind wird
der besucher und könnten die vermutet
dass das bald verbrecher passiert sie
mysteriöse fall nach dem verschwinden
von normalen zürcher unterland gott
polizei jetzt von verbrechen uns jetzt
auto von vermissten völlig ins grand
gefunden der fall bornhauser macht
schweizweit schlagzeilen
bald wird spekuliert ob es sich um einen
mordfall ohne leiche handelt
die polizei führt mehrere großflächige
suchaktionen durch der aufwand beträgt
über 7200 mannstunden doch die leiche
findet die polizei nicht nur kleider von
chino bornhauser mit blutspuren
verstreut an verschiedenen orten im wald
um rafz
das steht luis rodrigues als er neun
jahre alt ist holt ihn seine mutter aus
brasilien in die schweiz
sie arbeitet in einer bar hat kaum zeit
für ihn
er beginnt mehrere lehren schließt aber
keine ab mit 20 lernt er dann seine
spätere frau andrea kennen viele ideen
viel elan viel freunde ja ich war so ein
gegensatz von hin so sind diese stille
maus und das hat mich je besser an ihm
angezogen und so haben wir uns auch
kennengelernt und nach und nach ist das
alles verschwunden er verbietet seiner
frau und den kindern nach draußen zu
gehen
überall sieht er gefahren für sie er
leidet an einer paranoiden
persönlichkeitsstörung und wer zum iv
bezüger seine wut lässt er an seiner
frau aus es kommt zu häuslicher gewalt
ich habe ihm auch ein ultimatum gestellt
wenn sich ja was nichts ändert dann gehe
ich ja weg
ich war ja dadurch depressiv lustlos ich
hatte keine kraft mehr irgendetwas zu
tun das hat mich einfach kaputt gemacht
fünf wochen nach der tat verhaftet die
polizei louis und andrea rodrigues den
entscheidenden hinweis geben die daten
von diesem bankomaten andrea rodrigues
wurde von louis beauftragt mit china
brawn hausers bankkarte geld abzuheben
doch der pin code ist falsch andrea roth
regers bezieht danach mit ihrer eigenen
karte geld der bankomat registriert
alles und führt die polizei zu luis
rodrigues in untersuchungshaft gesteht
der brasilianer das air kino bornhauser
umgebracht hat und erklärt dass seine
frau nichts mit dem fall zu tun habe
andrea roth regel wird nach zwei tagen
u-haft entlassen als lewis ein weiteres
mal von der polizei befragt wird kann
petra bornhauser zu hören sie sieht
erstmals den mutmaßlichen mörder ihres
mannes
das hat mir das so weiter da sitzen
eintracht hätte ihn geführt wird also
ist ja quasi ein schwerverbrechen
und genau dabei zx1 mir leid da sie
zeigen wie sie es ganz ganz schlimmes
angestellt
ja und annecy verhört worden
wir sind ihnen roxy sport der stadt in
der wir jetzt minuten kühlen tagen immer
wieder mal fast alles weg sagt sie
hassen lebt versteht dass man so was
macht
ich weiß nicht ich das beschreiben soll
es war einfach immer noch mein ehemann
ich war ja da bewährungs mal gesagt
haben in guten und in schlechten zeiten
im gefängnis fragen staatsanwaltschaft
und polizei den brasilianer immer wieder
wo er die leiche deponiert habe luis
rodrigues macht dann diese zeichnungen
sie sollen den ort zeigen wo er gino
bornhauser abgelegt hat auch in den
befragungen versucht er den ort zu
beschreiben wie diese protokolle zeigen
er zeichnet einen zaun dort habe er die
leiche bei einem baumstumpf abgelegt
vergraben habe er gino bornhauser nicht
an diesen zeichnungen und aussagen sind
jedoch zweifel angebracht denn luis
rodrigues selber dass er während der
fahrt mit der leiche einen filmriss
hatte und sich nicht orientieren konnte
die leiche bleibt verschwunden
2017 wird luis rodrigues wegen mordes
angeklagt der prozess in bülach soll im
dezember 2017 stattfinden
doch so weit kommt es nicht zweieinhalb
monate vor dem prozess in luis rodrigues
und sein zellennachbar abends im zürcher
flughafen gefängnis bircher müsli
danach spielen sie uno und schach laut
dem zellennachbarn schreibt luis
rodrigues dann einen brief er habe
gesagt dieser sei für seine frau wie
dieses einvernahmeprotokoll der polizei
zeigt am nächsten morgen liegt der 36
jährige brasilianer tot in seinem bett
laut dem rechtsmedizinischen gutachten
starb luis rodrigues an einer morphin
vergiftung von wem er das medikament
erhielt konnte die polizei nicht
herausfinden
als todesart kommen unfall und suizid in
frage mitarbeiter des forensischen
instituts zürich finden im wc und dem
abfall lehre medikamenten kapseln jedoch
keinen abschiedsbrief
foto angeblich nichts gefunden
das ist die asche von ihm
was dann so kleben aber ich weiß es
nicht das ist braucht einfach seine
freiheit das was er wollte natürlich
seine zigarette und weg und zwar mit
leben
das ist wie ein ersatz für mich also
wenn mein tag schwierig ist oder ich
mich schlecht fühle einsam
dann komme ich da und ja sprecher rhede
weiner
es ist als wäre er immer noch da
naja hoffe du hast deinen frieden
na ja vielleicht auch nicht wenn ich ihn
jeden tag voll gewahrt
ja
gerade da wo gott dafür petra bornhauser
wird sich wohl nie von ihrem mann
verabschieden können
seine leiche liegt vermutlich irgendwo
in einem wald zum zweiten mal besucht
sie den ort an dem ihr mann überfahren
und getötet wurde
doch hitze und lustig st
davis ocean jump lustigsten dahin
einzige maschine die alles abgesucht
warum ist der rechner noch wichtiger der
ort
aber vielleicht findet man einmal der
ort und zeigt so bischoff ja und der
satellit aufmerksam sind und das merken
dass wir einmal im auto zu machen
zu grabe tragen
das wäre mein wunsch
[Musik]
heute ist ein spezieller tag für andrea
rodrigues mulmiges gefühl im magen
ich war seit dem tag auch gar nicht hier
das ist wieder das ist dass maurer wir
spielen gehen auf diesem parkplatz
schlug ihr mancino bornhauser nieder
andrea rodriguez arbeitet wieder als
lewis noch zu hause war durfte sie das
nicht auch für die kinder hat sich das
leben verändert ist dass die kinder
brauchen draußen sein und freunde
treffen
kinder seien die kinder wissen dass ihr
vater einen menschen umgebracht hat und
dann im gefängnis gestorben ist
mehr wissen sie nicht diesen herbst
kommt es dann zu einem ganz besonderen
treffen zwischen andrea rodrigues und
petra bornhauser
denn während der dreharbeiten kam die
idee auf dass sich die zwei witwen
kennenlernen könnten
für petra bornhauser ist dieses treffen
ein lang gehegter wunsch sie will wissen
ob luis rodrigues die tat bereute
aber hat es ihm leid getan was denken
sie
das gestehen dass er das bedeutet er hat
mir sehr oft geschrieben dass da gar
nicht nachgedacht hat was er dort hat
und hat schon bereut aber kommt das
nicht bekennt ich mache das ja nicht
sein
ja man kann gar nichts ändern ich denke
beide haben irgendwelche schult denke
ich jetzt mal dass ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen was man gesagt hat dass
ihr mann so naja ich weiß auch nicht was
da geschehen ist also ich denke wir ohne
grund wäre es nicht passiert ist und er
war stur und dickköpfig und meint er
müsste sich beweisen und ich denke es
war mein mann auch er konnte nicht
aufhören
ob sie sieht lebt ihr keine schuld in
diesem sinn sagen wir schon viele aber
ich hab so große schuld gefühl in mir
rein weil wenn er verärgert war war
etwas hatte mir verärgert hat seine wut
immer zu hause an meer abgelassen und
sie sagte zu ihm ja wenn dich jemand
verärgert lass es dort von wo es
gekommen ist und nicht bei mir
dann gebe ich mir ja dafür schuld dass
ich so etwas gesagt habe
ja denke wir müssen über das hinweg
kommen und versuchen unser leben
weiterzuführen
[Musik]
wie mit einem verbrechen umgehen diese
zwei frauen sind dabei einen weg zu
finden
doch ganz damit abschließen werden sie
wohl nie können